MODERATOR: What has
been your biggest
learning in creating all of
this Shiny for Python magic?
Oh man, the biggest
learning, there's been so much.
A lot of different
components involved
in building this stuff.
There's building
Shiny for Python
itself, which was a really
good learning experience.
I hadn't really done a whole lot
of Python programming before.
But having the opportunity
to implement Shiny again
has been really interesting.
It's sort of--
it's given us a lot
of chances to think about
hey, how do we-- do we really
want to do things this way?
Can we do things a better way?
With this web stuff,
there's so much
JavaScript programming and
TypeScript for programming.
And just learning what
the possibilities are here
has been super
fun, and it's been,
it's been really exciting to
push the boundaries of what's
possible.
I feel like we're using stuff
right now that's sort of
at the edge of what's
possible, like hey,
I want to build something--
what I wish I had was something
that-- system that did this.
And then being able
to go and build that,
that's been really fun.
I feel like it's juggling
all the pieces, like in making
the transition from
exploration to Shiny,
like knowing when to
stop exploring the data
and to move it into a Shiny app.
And also, like just how to get
autocomplete for everything
has been really helpful.
A lot of people think
about writing in VS code.
And you can't do it like in
a notebook in VS code, too,
but I think the
reason notebooks are
so useful is that oftentimes, I
want to autocomplete data, too.
And that's not like
a static analysis.
You can't just sit
down with a script
and autocomplete the
columns of your data.
So to me, it's been that
dance of like auto-completing
the names of columns and stuff
and being able to build an app.
That's a really weird,
actually I think uniquely,
data science space.
It's hard to put
yourself in the shoes
of the users of
something like this
if, by definition, you are
someone writing this app you
have experience and you're not
boots on the ground writing
these apps every day.
And so it's very easy to
forget what's important
and to prioritize
the wrong things.
The biggest like
long-term learning thing
has been to not trust my
immediate intuition about what
is the most important thing
to prioritize in development
because I'm probably wrong.
As a data scientist,
I still think
that R is, you know, is
very much my tool of choice
if I'm doing that
kind of work, where
I'm working with a new
data set, trying to find
interesting things from it.
But coming to Python
and now my day job
being more of a
software engineer,
where I'm the one
responsible for creating
the software that data
scientists will then use,
it's been a really nice
experience coming into Python
and there being
all of these kind
of really mature, sophisticated
libraries for building
kind of the foundational
piece of what you would need
for a framework like Shiny.
And not only that,
but using VS code
with things like
GitHub Copilot and just
like the integrations with
navigating large Python code
bases in VS Code and all
the extension ecosystem,
provides a really
rich experience
for navigating through large
code bases and learning Python.